rette sich wer kann flughafen kabul
gestern es sind bilder die das scheitern
des westens in diesem krieg fatale
illustrieren
irgendwo in kabul erreichen wir einen
der sich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
retten kann obwohl er jahrelang für die
bundeswehr und deren alliierte als
übersetzer tätig war
es ist beschämend für die deutsche
regierung dass sie nicht in der lage ist
uns jetzt zu schützen ich bereue es mit
den deutschen zusammengearbeitet zu
haben
wir zeigen den mann nicht um seine
identität um sein leben zu schützen denn
seit die taliban kabul inklusive
präsidentenpalast eingenommen haben muss
er sich mit seiner familie verstecken
ich habe alles dabei mein vertrag meine
registrierungsnummer mein pass alles ist
bei mir
haben die deutschen ihnen dokumente
gegeben um nach deutschland einreisen zu
können
sie haben uns gesagt dass wir an dem
sicheren ort sein sollen damit sie die
visa vorbereiten können wir waren fast
einen monat dort aber haben keine
antwort von den deutschen bekommen
gestern nachmittag werden die safe
hauses aufgegeben kurz danach von
patrouillierenden taliban entdeckt
die ersehnte rettung durch die deutschen
sie kam nicht
er hatte die sicheren unterkünften mit
spenden organisiert ex bundeswehrsoldat
markus kopien bei einer von denen die
monatelang für die ausreise der
ortskräfte gekämpft hatten wir haben der
bundesregierung seit mehreren monaten
vorschläge und ideen unterbreitet wie
man die ortskräfte retten hätte können
dafür hat uns am anfang nur geld und ein
bisschen politischer wille gefehlt am
ende wurde es dann nur noch das geld als
wir das geld dann hatten war es zu spät
die rolle der bundesregierung ja sie
haben dafür gesorgt dass die ortskräfte
in die hände der taliban
vor wenigen wochen im bundestag
deutschlands außenminister hält fragen
der opposition zur lage in afghanistan
für unnötig all diese fragen haben ja
die grundlage dass in wenigen wochen die
taliban in afghanistan
das zepter in der hand haben das ist
nicht die grundlage meiner annahme
gestern dann das fatale eingeständnis
von fehleinschätzung und planlosigkeit
wir alle die bundesregierung die
nachrichtendienste die internationale
gemeinschaft wir haben die lage falsch
eingeschätzt
heute fällt die bilanz der kanzlerin
über fast 20 kriegsjahre in afghanistan
ernüchternd aus an dieser stelle müssen
einfach konstatieren dass wir unsere
ziele nicht erreicht haben und wir
müssen darüber sprechen was die lehren
daraus für die zukunft sind harte worte
für einen der den einsatz seiner zeit
mit geplant hatte in der nonchalance mit
der man jetzt darüber hinweggeht dass so
viele menschen
körperlichen und seelischen schaden
genommen haben so viele soldaten ihr
leben gegeben haben für einen einsatz
der so endet das ist eine tragödie
größten ausmaßes
harald kujat generalinspekteur der
bundeswehr als deutschland mit amerika
nach dem elften september in den krieg
zieht es ist der erste nato bündnisfall
der geschichte
knapp 20 jahre später trifft die trump
administration und der außenminister die
taliban in doha friedensverhandlungen
spätestens jetzt sollte klar sein dass
die islamisten afghanistan einnähmen
werden
tatsache ist aber dass das amerikanische
militär das pentagon gewarnt haben
gesagt haben ihr verlasst euch nicht auf
die zusicherung der taliban das sind
lippenbekenntnisse und auch gesagt haben
wenn es tatsächlich dazu kommen dass die
taliban angreifen dann wird die
afghanische armee innerhalb kurzer zeit
kollabieren eine erkenntnis zu der die
bundesregierung offenbar erst heute
kommt in einem internen papier des
verteidigungsministeriums
das dem zdf vorliegt sieht sie den
erfolg der taliban in den zitat
dynamischen auflösungserscheinungen der
afghanischen sicherheitskräfte
dabei gab es hinweise genug als die
ausbildung der afghanischen
sicherheitskräfte im fokus der mission
stand da hätte allen klar sein müssen
sagt kujat was nach dem abzug passieren
wird
besteht weitgehend einvernehmen darüber
dass es im schnitt etwa ein drittel war
der ausgebildeten soldaten die dann
übergelaufen sind offensichtlich auch
polizisten daraus muss ich doch den
rückschluss ziehen dass der rest auch
über läuft wenn es wenn es heiß wird man
sagt ja nicht umsonst das wird die
flinte ins korn geworfen die haben die
flinte nicht ins korn geworfen sondern
sie haben sie mitgenommen
mitgenommen haben die taliban
mittlerweile auch was die nato truppen
der afghanischen armee überlassen haben
fotos stolz posieren der kämpfer
zusammen getragen von einem internet der
zählt alleine 16 funktionsfähige
helikopter 50 gepanzerte fahrzeuge und
mehrere tausend jobs und trucks aus us
beständen jetzt in händen der taliban
zur erinnerung ziel des einsatzes war al
kaida zu zerstören und dass von
afghanistan für die westliche welt keine
terror gefahr mehr ausgeht auch für
deutschland die sicherheit der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird auch am
hindukusch verteidigt
nachfrage in der bundespressekonferenz
das motto dass die sicherheit
deutschlands auch am hindukusch
verteidigt wird gilt das heute noch na
ja ich würde schon daran erinnern das
ist nicht die taliban waren die die
anschläge beispielsweise des 11
septembers in den usa verübt wurden
sondern terror kräfte denen sie erlaubt
haben sich in ihrem land einzunisten und
gegen dieses einnisten von terror kräfte
die uns und die gesamte westliche welt
und eben nicht nur die usa bedroht haben
dagegen war ja der einsatz berichtete
dass von afghanistan keine
terroristische bedrohung mehr ausgehen
kann das ist eine illusion
wir wissen ja heute schon dass al kaida
nach wie vor im land ist dass der es
schon im land ist und in welcher weise
die taliban nun diese aktivitäten wieder
zu lassen das wissen wir natürlich noch
nicht aber die voraussetzungen dafür
sind natürlich da
taliban in polizeifahrzeugen heute in
kabul
es gibt vieles was an diesen bildern
beunruhigt dass die deutsche politik
sich von ihnen so überrascht wie hilflos
zeigt dass die verteidigung der
sicherheit deutschlands am hindukusch
gescheitert ist und dieser 20 jährige
krieg so sinnlos gewesen sein soll